bonsoir enchanté un très joli très très
joli très jolie je comprends pas
pourquoi vous étiez pas content
d'Azur franchement
c'était donc le 8 décembre 2001 vous
étiez Miss Lyon et vous êtes devenus
Miss France alors on va parler de vos
mensurations m'en voudrait pas parce que
pour une mise c'est la moindre des
choses
88 64 92
à peu près ça à peu près ça alors
problème c'est la taille
72 parce que c'est que les mises doivent
faire un mètre 72 et on a dit que vous
faisiez 68 61 attendez michoir
forrestres
de contestation l'année dernière
c'est vrai finalement que j'ai entendu
que c'était un homme
la tête vous avez pas vu qu'elle était
Miss Europe là qu'elle est super bon
c'est pas grave toute façon les hommes
aussi en boîte Miss France après tout
personne n'est parfait
bien alors Sylvie avant d'être miss
France vous destiniez à la profession
d'avocate voilà vous avez fait des
études à Lyon et vous avez fait une
maîtrise de droit
est-ce que vous avez vraiment cette
parce qu'il y a un truc quand même en 98
vous déclarez vivre toujours chez vos
parents au sable d'Olonne et en 2001
vous dites que vous êtes à Lyon depuis 4
ans je sais pas expliquer moi comment
c'est possible ça
à Nantes et j'ai fait ma licence et ma
maîtrise à Lyon d'accord donc si on
calcule j'ai eu ma maîtrise en juin 2001
donc je suis arrivée à Lyon je suis pas
très loin
on est cool c'est bon
si vous voulez je l'ai pas sur le
plateau
ouais c'est aussi mes amours donc elle
dit DVD a gagné si vous donnez le nom de
l'épouse de Gad Elmaleh de la concubine
bien alors la mode des propositions de
la mode non
des invitations à des anniversaires
vous aimez les boîtes de temps
moi j'adore le ton alors et avec Xavier
ça se passe très bien malheureusement
vous aviez on voit pas beaucoup dans
l'année puisque je suis essentiellement
avec
genevièvement
Xavier ce sont les moments très sympa il
est venu m'apporter un petit cadeau pour
aménager mon studio
méfiez-vous avec Xavier c'est tout lui
ça dites-moi vodka
problème
pas facile bah quand ils ont préparé
l'élection de Miss France à Agadir vos
copines ont dit que vous étiez froides
hautaines voire prétentieuse Sylvie
ce sont les commentaires des 45 je
m'incline maintenant j'aimerais savoir
si c'est vraiment le commentaire des 45
candidates parce que vous les avez bien
[ __ ] d'une certaine façon
on peut pas plaire à tout le monde
vous avez bien aimé
c'est vrai que vous avez un petit peu
une carapace c'est bien
quand tu étais toute petite c'est pas en
le disait de toute façon il disait elle
a un sondage elle est distante elle dit
toujours très souvent dans les articles
sur les Miss France il y a un truc qui
me frappe c'est des encadrés dans les
journaux des accroches énormes ou la
miss dit attention je suis aussi
intelligent un article où j'ai dit je ne
suis pas quelqu'un
non mais c'est vrai comme vous êtes
avocate vous êtes avocat attention
vous avez une maîtrise de droit vous
êtes
mort ça je suis peut-être Miss France
mais je suis intelligente
non mais vous êtes presque avocate c'est
normal en même temps bon parce que vous
êtes un petit peu plus âgé que les
filles d'habitude voilà c'est tout
d'habitude ils ont 18 ans ils ont jamais
rien fait 23 ans
c'est pas possible
alors maintenant on en arrive au point
crucial à l'amoureux grave
alors le problème c'est qu'il habite pas
à Lyon
elle est tranquille
ça donne je suis désolé je viens ça
donne une histoire un petit peu décousue
pourquoi des cousines parce que bon elle
est livrée elle-même lui il sait pas ce
qu'elle fait ça vous inquiète pas ça les
ignore les plus solides sont basés sur
la confiance bien sûr
Juliette absolument il est où je pense
que Monsieur Thierry Ardisson m'a
répondu
politique
est-ce que vous croyez sérieusement que
votre amour va survivre à un an de règne
pourquoi
c'est vous que j'aurais acheté pour
faire un truc chaud si j'étais Arthur
alors vous savez que Miss France est
obligé d'être en phase avec l'opinion
publique française Sylvie donc on va
vous faire c'est normal une interview
opinion publique
[Applaudissements]
on a une mission
attention dans 69% des couples c'est la
femme qui fait le ménage et chez vous
moi si c'est pas moi qui le fait
personne le fait
des couples la femme fait la cuisine et
chez vous
pareil je vis toute seule donc si je
fais pas la cuisine
elle prend le TGV donc des plats froids
mais je sais que je suis pas très grande
cuisine 38% des femmes font l'amour au
réveil et 73 au coucher et vous
c'est les jours
pourquoi la pleine lune il fonctionne
bien
des vergondé Geneviève depuis qu'on a
touché le magot j'aime bien
j'ai rien touché du tout pas vous allez
toucher bon j'ai rien touché on essaie
de savoir on est bien d'accord si sylvie
est en face avec l'opinion publique
française pour une Miss France c'est la
moindre des choses
56% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
dans le noir et vous
[Rires]
font l'amour où il veut quand il veut et
vous non
pas possible
il y a un problème technique on n'aime
pas les matchs
demande à leur partenaire ce qu'elles
veulent qui lui fasse et vous
non ici l'improvise mal il est jeté
un numéro on peut demander des conseils
font l'amour
lors de la première rencontre et vous
rentrez à la maison 49% des femmes
refusent de se faire attacher
je fais partie de ce 49%
[Applaudissements]
trop bon la ceinture mix comme ça
je dis pas attaché ligoté comme ça comme
un
fou
c'est pareil ça revient le système de la
soumission j'aime pas 66 % des femmes
sont choqués par les pratiques sadomaso
oh c'est marrant ça et vous
choqué non parce que je pense qu'il y a
des degrés
ça dépend si on est avec un foulard en
soi
alors
un petit peu
marrant ça 65 % des Françaises refusent
des relations à trois bah oui moi
genevièvement
non pareil pareil parce que relation à
trois j'aime pas partager et puis si au
bout de quelques temps de relation vous
commencez à 3 ou 10 ans vous finissez à
c'est pas vrai parce que
c'est pas moins mal
a besoin de quelqu'un d'autre pour pour
s'éclater j'ai rien à faire là
il s'agit de doubler le plaisir
après l'amour
36% des Françaises se lavent
29% d'Ores 8% fume 7% boivent ou manges
6% recommence et 5% regardent la télé
je me lave
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu